and now in San Francisco Westfield Mall
most of you have been to a Westfield
Mall they're all over the country the
nicest malls that we have all over
America are usually Westfield malls well
Westfield Mall in San Francisco I
believe it is closed as of yesterday
once a crown jewel for retail shopping
tonight the Westfield San Francisco
Center is pulling the plug on its famed
downtown mall the stunning decision to
walk away comes as the city struggles
with homelessness an open-air drug
market and the perception of crime
did you catch that at the end local news
it's the perception of crime there's a
broken window it's the perception of
crime do you know that people in San
Francisco and around San Francisco area
it's also Oakland and some of the areas
around there people don't leave bags in
their cars anymore because people if
they see a bag on the car they just
break the window and they steal what's
inside there are literally people I've
seen this repeatedly and I've read about
it there are people now in San Francisco
area who when they get out of their car
if they have to park on the street
sometimes they put the windows down with
nothing else in their car because they
they're going on the assumption that all
right these these petty crime people
they don't know how to steal a car right
they don't know how to hotwire a car so
they'll leave the car although they
might take a dump in it but but they'll
that at least they won't break the
windows then to see you know because
they'll see that there's nothing in
there that is the level of what is going
on in San Francisco so I wanted to show
you so as we were putting this together
I was like you know it's sometimes it
feels a little heavy-handed when you
show this this endless State of Decay in
San Francisco but I want to show you
this video we're going to play it we
took the audio out because there was a
copyright issue because there was a song
playing over it but we can throw to it
and I'll just talk over it this is a
video there's an account that runs
basically uh it's a guy who lives in San
Francisco area who just walks around and
and shows you these These are sprawling
parts of the city so this is not all
just in one area I mean look at look at
this person
this is what's going on in San Francisco
this is the progressive what they would
say is the progressive Utopia but how
much closer to a dystopia this is and
I'm not being heavy-handed when we're
showing you this this is all over San
Francisco people that literally look
like they potentially are dead and and
certainly soon will be dead uh there are
there are very few I mean and trust me
there's there's hundreds of those videos
and it's and it's never stopping there
it's never stopping there but again
these are why is this happening in
places where it's Democrats are in
charge progressives are in charge right
there is a reason because they get
basically everything wrong and then they
blame you for it and then guys like
Gavin Newsom uh get Democrat privilege
right they get to succeed and further
their career and political Ambitions and
go from mayor to governor and
undoubtedly he wants to become president
[Music]
thank you